thank you hey
great to be back please
sit down nobody who's here thank you oh
i'm kidding what a great
this moment all right we're back in the
studio
nobody here we're back in the studio oh
man it's been a long time i was in my
office today there was a family of
raccoons in my desk
but uh oh i guess we dodged a bullet
there with hurricane
laura uh it uh hit but not too bad uh
boy but it was a hurricane did some
damage
i was thinking today if only jerry
falwell senior
was alive to blame it on his son
but uh yeah jerry falwell junior just
he's in trouble
he apparently his wife was having an
affair
with the pool boy the pool boy and uh
you know allegedly
just allegedly he would he would watch
um
uh he says he you know he did not have
sex himself with the with the pool boy
he's an evangelical he's not a snake
handler
but uh but he would allegedly watch from
the corner of the room
so so at least social distancing was
maintained
but i don't know if he was watching the
republican convention it was a great
week if you love reality shows but hate
reality
uh boy did you see did you see trump's
speech last night
by the end of trump's speech there were
three fact checkers were taken into the
concussion protocol
i mean
the people in the crowd were chanting
four more lies
four more lies
but uh but we learned a lot from
watching the convention i did
i think what we learned is that donald
trump loves women and immigrants
he's a humble but brutally honest
patriot and he hates corruption
and he has built the greatest economy
since man began to walk erect
and the proof of that is that the demand
these days
for coffins plywood rocks bottles
and replacement plate glass has never
been higher
yes it's it's so bizarre that at the
republican convention they just kept
talking
about rioting and looting and vandalism
that you can expect
under a democratic rule except that's
happening now
under trump and yet their theme is that
all of the rioting and the violence
you're seeing now wouldn't be happening
if somebody like donald trump was in the
white house
[Music]
this guy is some salesman you know
because in 2016 it was like i will end
american carnage
and in 2020 it's like there's only one
person who can stop
what's happening under me me
and that's why we must elect donald
trump so we can re-gratify
america again again
[Laughter]
yes some of these speakers that they had
at the convention they painted a very
ugly picture of this country kimberly
guilfoyle
you know don junior's girlfriend she's
she said democrats want to destroy the
country
wow and matt gates said that they're
going to
democrats are going to invite ms-13 to
live next door
i wouldn't do that i and the mccluskies
remember that couple from st
louis they they said that the democrats
want to abolish the suburbs and
oh and then jerry falwell jr said under
the democrats
you'll have to watch the pool boy [ __ ]
your wife i mean
it's dead boy those democrats
yeah kimberly gulfoyle boy did you see
her speech she was very
off the rails when they go low she goes
loud
yeah be in bed with that girl be like
say
my name
but why is she even speaking
why is she speaking six of the twelve
key speakers at the republican
convention were named trump
you know we used to have former
presidents and elder statesmen
speak at conventions now it's like uh
hey dad would it be okay if my
girlfriend spoke at the convention
well you know wally uh girlfriends don't
usually speak
at conventions but i i suppose it'll be
all right
yeah well another week another police
shooting of an unarmed black man
and uh to protest this which yes we
should
and we need to uh the nba and and
baseball players a lot of them
they they did not play this week and boy
this is going to get people's attention
because rioting is one thing but
forcing men to talk to their wives
you